I started off in in the Noir genre as we  talked about earlier and that's a genre  in which you define character through  action  people can talk about who they are and  what motivates them but you don't trust  them you wait and see what do they  actually do what do they do to each  other and that's essential to the way  that genre works I think that's the most  strong form of characterization and  I think in various ways all the films  I've done have relied on that film Noir  Dynamic whether it's science fiction you  know like Interstellar Inception or  action films like the dog night trilogy  there's always an underlying film Noir  Dynamic there's always this this  question of let's  let's judge the characters based on what  they do rather than than what they say